greetings from podcastville what's
happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey's joint is here and it's
brought to you by
draftkings jesus [ __ ] christ
what a tremendous ufc this weekend world
series
you got it all and if you haven't tried
it yet draftkings is america's top
rated sportsbook app this saturday
halloween it's time for the showdown
in happy valley it's penn state versus
ohio
state this game is as [ __ ] huge
as [ __ ] king kong's dick you
understand me
this is a [ __ ] game right here to
celebrate it draftking sportsbook
is giving all new users the chance to
turn one dollar
into 100 did you hear me one dollar
into 100 just by betting either team
download the top rated sports king
sportsbook app now and use code joey
again draftking sportsbook app now
and use code joey you're not going to
miss this offer
pick either penn state or ohio state bet
one dollar
on them and cash one hundred dollars if
they win
that's one dollar to win a hundred
dollars i don't know about you
you know what's better than one dollar
two dollars
anyway right now that one dollar to win
100
when you use promo code joey during
signing
for a limited time only at draftkings
sports book so right now
why [ __ ] around the world series is
still on it's monday morning
who the [ __ ] knows what happened you
know baseball is it
khabib retired and i don't feel so good
myself
so do yourself a favor pick either penn
state or ohio state
better dollar and win 100.
when you sign up at draftkingsportsbook
using promo code joey
and here's the part the lawyers might
want me to say you got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana or pennsylvania only
deposit bony requires 25 times played
playthrough
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help all right you got to call
1-800 gambler or if you're in
indiana call 1-809 with it
but first [ __ ] download the draftking
sportsbook app
and use promo code joey before you go
tap it out on a [ __ ]
the church is also brought to you by all
reliable
[ __ ] onyx.com alpha brain 100
money back guarantee even if you don't
like the product
shrooms tech immune and shroom tech
sport
important during this [ __ ] winter
season right now you want to be prepared
i'm all out of new mood because i
[ __ ] take them
and i'm all out of melatonin spray i
think i got one melatonin spray
which helps me to sleep like a
[ __ ] do yourself a favor go to
honor.com right now and press in
church c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent
off
of on it products delivered to your
house whether it be the coconut
chocolate nuggets whatever they got you
want to try go to honor.com right now
and press church and right now
we're going to start this little
[ __ ] podcast
kick kick it [ __ ]
hey how you doing come on
look who it is what's happening
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
greetings to uncle joey's joint it's a
beautiful
monday october the 25th who's [ __ ]
better than you
nobody let's get to it we got a lot to
talk about today i want to analyze
something with you guys
just so you see what the [ __ ] happens in
life from time to time
uh i know most of you guys watch the
justin gagey
khabib number golf whatever his [ __ ]
name is the fight
you know it was a great line
if you took geisha at 285 you weren't
wrong
i mean i'm not mad at you uh
we got to talk about this i know a lot
of you maybe don't watch the ufc
but i want to go over the situation
because it applies to life you know
gage just came off one of the biggest
wins in ufc history
he pretty much took apart tony ferguson
if you don't know donald ferguson is
he's uh mexican kid heart of a [ __ ]
tiger works out a tent planet jiu jitsu
makes his own
gyms does his own training camps uh
cardio specialist and i mean justin
gagey
went in there and made him look like a
[ __ ] child a few months ago you know
maybe a year ago who the [ __ ] knows
with this pandemic my memory is [ __ ]
guts you know
uh last night he's supposed to fight
khabib who
hasn't fought a while uh he
beat dustin justin por dustin poirier
uh [ __ ] just unbelie anybody he's
gone through
uh except for maybe alex gave him a long
fight
it was a last qualified but that's not
the point i'm getting to
um you know his last performance was
sensational also khabib
so you're looking at this kid he's 28 no
he lost his father
uh nobody knew how he was going to react
and he went in there and just you know
went through geishi
again i have no ill will i'm not
bad martin uh justin at all
justin's a great fighter uh nine bonuses
and seven fights young kid still has the
world by the balls
nothing you know not he lost nothing but
a loss last night
if anything he learned something about
himself which is what i'm trying to get
to here um
it's really weird how when you look at
things okay
when you look at things when you when
you're trying to come up in your life
you look at things and they appear
bigger than what they are
you only can make them uh smaller to get
yourself into context
are you with me are you following me on
this sometimes it's a big picture
it you know your mind your mind controls
everything in a situation like that
for if you watched that fight last night
that wasn't
even close to the justin gagey that
we've seen fight before we've seen like
maybe two punches
he threw like two or three good
combinations but that wasn't the justin
gagey we've seen before
at the end the triangle the way it went
down i mean i'm not taking away nothing
from khabib
i just want you to understand what i'm
talking about that
justin went in there and he made khabib
bigger than what he was sometimes in
life we do that
you know if i were to listen to the
people i went on the road with
when i was doing the triple runs early
on in 95 and 96
i wouldn't be here because they were all
very negative
about l.a they were painting a picture
for me of la
of a place that you could not get spots
you were not going to get up on stage
nobody was going to talk to you the
comics were going to hate you
i mean there was every negative in the
world
when i looked at moving to l.a which i
wasn't really in it to move to l.a
i got in it just to do comedy just to
try to be
normal i accepted my fate i was a loser
i like doing drugs i like cracking jokes
i like waking up in different hotels
and that was it i just didn't want to
live the normal life so i made
a decision on my own nobody made it for
me
to [ __ ] go into this style of living
did i enjoy it yes i did while i was
doing it could i continue it forever no
i couldn't but
what we're discussing here is the
picture that i was a young
not really i wasn't young at all i was
32 33 years old
i was already long too long in the tooth
to be [ __ ] featuring
but the people i was featuring for those
headliners were all very bitter
and they were my age right now they were
55 50 to 55
48 to 55 and i got to tell you something
man
i didn't i met one positive
two positive headliners in that time
when i was the broker i got the honor to
meet doug stanhope
who didn't give a [ __ ] and their subway
fare attacker comedy
is something that nobody ever saw before
and there was this other guy i met that
was a kind of he wasn't the best
comedian in the world
but he mixed magic with comedy and music
but he gave you a show he was an
entertainer and i remember that i
offered him my
place to stay spend the night and he uh
walked we woke up the next morning got
coffee
and he showed me the ins and outs of
comedy and he kind of let me know that i
could do whatever i
the [ __ ] i wanted to do so it's how you
see those things how you
approach those things i'm going to tell
you who had the same problem gage you
had
uh you know going into that
you're looking at them when i first shot
my special
years ago you know uh whatever socially
unacceptable
we did two shows the first show i went
out there and basically had a bag of
dicks
because i let the special overtake me
then i went back inside
and looked at the special from a
different perspective and i went out
there and did the best job i could do
the producers of that show today say
that my material sucked
whatever i don't really give a [ __ ] but
i didn't feel that i performed
up to my potential on those specials
when i did the netflix special it was
the same thing
i got there and i didn't feel like i
performed
up to my abilities i'll tell you what
when i'm at the comedy store or any
other club you can't [ __ ] stop me
i'm a [ __ ] wild man in heat but when
i know that there's a camera in the back
and i'm trying to tighten up i'm trying
to beat john mulaney
somebody who i'm not that's when it gets
[ __ ] crazy you know
and sometimes we get those big
situations are never gonna happen again
and we blow them
and sometimes we rise to the occasion
when you pay
25 to 30 bucks to come see me on a
nightly basis
i rise to the [ __ ] occasion okay i go
[ __ ] nuts but when you're shooting a
special
you're getting all this information
thrown at you
and if you can't survive those that's
just hey listen
i do voice overs i do movies
i do tv shows i do animation i did soap
operas
there's not much uncle joey can't do but
i gave you two mediocre specials
on the one [ __ ] album this is me or
the priest it's a great album
because i had no idea i was being taped
and i didn't give a [ __ ]
see when i give a [ __ ] that's when i do
my best work
and last night justin gagey was giving a
[ __ ]
he shouldn't have gave a [ __ ] he would
he should have gone in there more
relaxed
like he did against tony ferguson but
that's hindsight
is 20 20. okay you're looking at that
now this morning
and you have to imagine how gagey feels
two days later
that he didn't stick to his original
game plan or whatever the [ __ ] it was
because
i mean khabib took him down with uh with
30 seconds left in the first round and
then he took him down with four minutes
left in the second round and you already
knew
what direction he was going once once
the beat deflates your ego
you lost the [ __ ] fight you know
you're gonna spend the rest of the time
on your back
again no no not disrespecting justin
gagey
what uh khabib at all i'm just looking
at the situation
and you ask yourself what happened how
can i thought it was going to be a five
round
smacking tack with teeth flying head
dudes going
wigs going i thought this was going to
be a bond runner or a fight you know and
so did everybody else
uh i ended up going to my daughter's
halloween party
it ended perfectly at 4 51 so i ended up
going to my daughter's halloween party
at the karate school so
i didn't lose out on nothing i had a
great [ __ ] time
but i'm just saying that when you look
at those situations
don't look engaged and say oh god gage
he just gave up no
he was overwhelmed sometimes in life
it's okay to be overwhelmed
it's okay man it happens you go to take
that final
and you know you go in there and
you ever over study have you ever over
studied
do you remember over studying like when
you [ __ ] do too much studying
and then you actually get to the test
and [ __ ] you went blank
and you said what the [ __ ] is this how
could this happen i've been studying for
18 [ __ ] days in a row
me and the korean kid we've been laying
it down i've been smelling this [ __ ]
kimchi for [ __ ] 10 days
and i still got a [ __ ] d how the [ __ ]
does this happen
that's the worst when you actually
prepare for something
and you [ __ ] get a d or something and
you're like what the [ __ ] happened
that's just a preparation for life guys
that's a preparation for life those
papers that they throw at you
and they just [ __ ] your world up you
wanted to stay home with me me last
night and watch
mom on [ __ ] paramount and you got
stoned instead of [ __ ] studying
and you [ __ ] happened it happens it
happens and you go and they throw a
complete left curve on you
that's what college is for okay so next
time you're in college and you're like
this professor sucks
i hate him maybe if gaiji and joey diaz
had him they would have done a better
life because you find out what a
surprise attack is
when i got into comedy i've never really
been overwhelmed like that before
that situation isn't commonly
overwhelmed yeah you get overwhelmed you
got a court in front of a judge
that type of [ __ ] overwhelms everybody
going to prison but jesus christ
bombing in the utah you can't figure it
out especially when you've been writing
for three days
all your best utah jokes i don't even
know any jokes about utah
but i'm just [ __ ] saying that this is
it's the same
thing being prepared mentally as just
as being prepared like like you could
study all you want you can put as much
time into it
but if you're not prepared mentally for
the [ __ ] shot they're gonna give you
i love it i love it i love when it
happens to me
like a couple weeks ago i was bitching
at you guys i ate a bag of dicks
trust me i was a little upset on the
upper thermos of my skins
but deep deep down inside of my soul i
was kind of happy
because it's good to get a setback from
time to time you got to get take a
little beating from time to time to move
forward
and it doesn't have to be physically
nobody's going to touch you physically
you want your mental you have to say
what the [ __ ] is going on
it's like what's going on with the
pandemic and made a lot of people
rethink that [ __ ] situation
a lot of people are we're not going to
that way you know some people tried to
look
listen to me there's some people in new
york that are trying to try
to throw a 10 000 people wedding in new
york
like when you when i get invited to a
wedding that 10 000 people gonna go
there
i just rip up the invitation i'm not
gonna go mingle with ten thousand people
at your shitty [ __ ] wedding
just because you're going to release
dubs into the [ __ ] air that's not
what i want to do
but there's people that during covert
right now
with the numbers going up they want to
have a wedding with 10 000 [ __ ]
people what do you want me to do
what would you do you know and they
don't want you to wear a mask
what would you do you know i mean people
are [ __ ] crazy right now there's
no way to look at it but
i even lost my mind and hate nobody
could prepare for this pandemic nobody
prepared for this
but once you saw what it was
you accepted it you made your points on
how you were gonna act and how you
weren't gonna act through it
like this is not going to scare me i'm
still going to go [ __ ] jump into a
room
i'm going to go into a back room with a
chinese restaurant and make sure they're
all from honda
and [ __ ] get their zip codes you know
if that's what you want to do
go do it i i you know you have to look
at this however you want to do it
i prepare myself in cold video
situations
and situations you know you're white
outside you're wide open your social
distance
you wash your hands and you don't
scratch your dick so you don't you don't
want your dick to get covered
the little [ __ ] pee hole gets all
shrunk up it looks like a [ __ ] up
eye looks like my eyes if you've noticed
my eyes aren't matching no more
one's going downwards one going up with
it's like you got a car accident with
your car
and the [ __ ] headlight looks down
from now on and you can't fix it
it happens it's what goes on during time
you get old you i'm saying
but yeah sometimes
life situations get a little too big for
you they're too hard to comprehend
doesn't mean you're weak
doesn't mean you need a psychiatrist
doesn't mean you need to join psych
scientology doesn't need you need to
join nexum
and get [ __ ] by some cult leader you
don't need anything
you just need to step back analyze the
situation
ah sometimes a joint helps
but sometimes you just gotta have a long
talk with yourself and
and say to yourself what the [ __ ]
happened i guarantee gage he's gonna
come back
stronger than ever he's a young kid he's
gonna come back stronger than ever
the question is you know how did khabib
just go in there
and do that like that with a [ __ ]
vertical triangle on the second round
you know i mean it's just little things
and again congratulations to khabib
i wanted to congratulate how he walked
off into the sunlight
as a champion he walked out of there he
didn't crawl out on his [ __ ] knees
these guys that should have disappeared
years ago khabib went out the right way
that nobody needs to tell you when to
[ __ ] leave
you need to do it on your own you know
he had a great relationship with his
father
he has a great relationship with javi
mendes you know and
uh he did the right thing i mean let's
face it he cleaned out the whole [ __ ]
division
you're gonna see all the tough guys
raising their hands now
look at us we're ready to go bring them
back khabib don't need to prove himself
to nobody he did everything he already
had to do
in a fashion that was [ __ ] tremendous
so
congratulations to him congratulations
to justin
this doesn't mean anything you will be
the world champion one day
and this is how you learn from different
[ __ ] things you know what makes you
tick you have to figure out what makes
you
take you know um i went to
my daughter's kickboxing class yesterday
at 10 in the morning
why because that's what parents do uh
usually i'd be
waking up in a hotel uh going downstairs
to get the free [ __ ] breakfast and
going back to my room
but thankful for covid i've been able to
take a breather from that
and been able to enjoy life you guys
want more stories i gotta go get em
i gotta go get em before i can go on a
stand-up door
i gotta go live through this pandemic
life so we have something to talk about
so i went to my daughter's kickboxing
class yesterday morning i'm sitting
there
i'm thinking to myself does my daughter
even like doing this [ __ ]
you know a couple weeks ago we went to
jimmy florentine sons game
and there was a bunch of girls playing
and i asked i go you want me to sign you
up in the league
again i'm not pistol pete's father i'm
not a communist dad i don't want you to
do nothing you don't want to do
i just want you to do what makes you
happy as a child
this is what they did with me and this
is why i ended up the way i did
i'm doing it with mercy under a little
bit more control in a controlling manner
like hey listen if you don't want to do
it that's fine
but you gotta figure out something not
to do and that's what my mother did with
me and that's how i got into martial
arts
and so what and so you know whatever
but after class you know uh
should we have a deal in the house if
she does the her martial arts class on
that day
she could play with a switch whatever
the [ __ ] that is it's like some
she gets minecraft on that but she
doesn't go into the evil part of
minecraft
because she has nightmares she keeps it
all sunny and [ __ ] like that i guess i
don't even know what minecraft is guys
i watch to play the game to make sure
there's no [ __ ]
people on there jerking off hitting each
other with their dicks on their head
i don't need that [ __ ] on my daughter's
computer when she's at school with the
zoom
which no more it's four days a week now
only zoom one one day take your zuma
lugia and shove it up your [ __ ]
muffler
i don't like your [ __ ] zoom anyway
i'm doing the zoom tomorrow
uh with my magnus pappas and the [ __ ]
hyenas and [ __ ]
so i'm excited to be with those
[ __ ] but
i was looking at mercy and i was saying
to myself you know we have this deal
where uh if she uh you know
does this she gets the stick and no
she's not in the door 10 minutes and
she's like that
where's the stick and my daughter my
wife gives it a stick
and then we have mints in the back and
my wife takes her out there one day a
week just to
do the mitts and stuff and she does the
mitts
then she gets the [ __ ] stick you know
but
i've sat with her you know a couple
times and said look
i don't want you to do this
because you're making me happy i'm happy
just having you just you being a
nice sweet little girl but whatever you
don't want to do
just tell me and we'll [ __ ] get our
money back and we'll move on to
something else i know that
in here that's why people like well you
should get a swing in the backyard for
what
they jump on the swing for two days and
the swing sits there like a [ __ ]
antique
and i'm the one down the g note for a
swing in the house that gets filled with
the fighters
and then she's got a string at the
[ __ ] park and every kid's house she
goes to the neighborhood has a swing
why don't you get a pool in the backyard
again i'm gonna get in the bubble ground
pool like a [ __ ] puerto rican on the
third
you know you're swimming it two or three
times
and then they go to the uh municipal
pool
which is [ __ ] everybody joins in the
summer and your pool sits there like a
[ __ ] spirit
so you know i'm gonna build a clubhouse
in the back
i got my man dominic lombardosi
who played fat tony soleno one of the
best young actors out there great man
always active on twitter supports
[ __ ]
uh comedians he built a [ __ ] fort
during the pandemic
i guess he had a company to come in and
built the fort it's [ __ ] beautiful
if you talk to dominic lombardosi on
twitter
hit him up say put a picture up for the
fort and that's what i'm gonna do
because nobody on the [ __ ] block
got a fort for that [ __ ] kid i might
as well put a fort up there
and i could hide a couple things myself
in there and i went to you know what i'm
saying
like i was back in prison remember i
used to hide everything in the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you gotta listen to the stories
[ __ ] anyway but it was really
weird because i was looking at my
daughter and i do not
want her to feel like she has to go to
college because of us
i don't want her to have those feelings
i want her to
do what she does and thank god
she's a natural student thank god she
loves school
she runs to that bus guys knock on wood
i mean i got it all covered there thank
god she gets after my mother's side
and from my side i enjoyed school to me
it was a [ __ ] social activity so i
didn't mind going to school
but at the end of that pattern
that night i must have thought about a
little more i must have written about it
i thought about my life and i thought
about all the things i've done
and everything i've done in a way
has been for people
and if you think
i gave a [ __ ] about my life growing up
i didn't as far as i was concerned
by the age of 25 or 26 once i got out of
prison
i was pretty much damaged goods i really
thought that about myself
okay i tried everything
you know but again you can't put a silk
out of the pig
i tried making my confirmation i tried
going to naropa institute
and learning buddhism i tried bettering
myself from all these things
but that wasn't the answer i was looking
for i was looking for a
a better answer you know what man as
much as you people may think
as much as you we laugh about and
everything yes
i was a criminal but when i got locked
up
and i came out that was one thing on my
[ __ ]
some people have a bucket list i have a
bucket list i wanna
i want to jump off a cliff with 10 dicks
as parachutes that's great
i don't know you know i ain't got a
bucket list all right i got a list of
what i want to do and what i want to
[ __ ] conquer
and that's what i need to do so the
first thing on that list became
not going back to prison
okay that was that was predisposed
right from the [ __ ] start i was not
going back to prison
there was nothing i could do if i went
back to prison so
what i did to [ __ ] him combat that was
i still did little crimes
misdemeanors type crimes crimes i could
talk myself out of
times that i would end up with probation
you know i would do
crimes that would you know not really
affect the status quo of things i wasn't
using weapons anymore
you weren't going to catch me [ __ ]
selling a drug even though
i did sell drugs from time to time but i
ca it wasn't like
you know some guy was calling me saying
can you get two ounces for a friend
that's how they get you don't know
nothing if it's somebody i know
and he's my goomba you know i was
pushing drugs that way
but i tried to every day when i got out
of prison
i tried to take that bad taste out of my
mouth i'm not gonna lie to you it's a
bad taste
we goof around it and we make fun of it
but it's a known fact that in 1988 i got
sentenced
and that's just the way life is i made a
mistake and i corrected myself
i tried to take something that didn't
belong to me and that's cool
whatever i did my time i knew one thing
i didn't want to be like those people
i didn't i wasn't going to end up no
50-year year
year old tattooed fat dude with [ __ ]
tattoos of every prison i went to that
that wasn't gonna happen
there was a lot more to life than going
to prison my friend
so [ __ ] the river duchy that's not
happening
you know when i was
trying to get my life together i used
people
i used the people around me as my
inspiration you know uh
here i was an i'm selling [ __ ] cars
i have a little thought about standing
com stand-up comedy
and this guy at [ __ ] the super
tutorial at the subaru store
jamandi who i'll never forget says to me
this is something you got to pursue
you know uh he had two boys of his own
he had no reason to give a [ __ ] about me
but for some reason he did at that time
i didn't want anybody to give the [ __ ]
up
i didn't want anybody to give a [ __ ]
about me but people did
people saw something in me that maybe i
didn't see so
he kept bugging me about getting into
stand-up comedy
and in a way i just want down that it
did it i just went down in
to do it because he would always talk
about goals and what you had to do to
you know beat your goals and stuff like
that i just did
comedy as a [ __ ] whim to please him
and to lie to myself i thought if when i
first got into comedy i thought it was
lying to myself
like you know like a like an amway
salesman like they become an amway cell
and they're like oh my god i'm gonna
make a million dollars
but in the back of their mind who the
[ __ ] you're gonna sell that toilet paper
to you know what i'm saying
you already selling all that toilet
paper and all that soap so knock it off
then you gotta find pyramids
that's how i thought comedy was
but i was wrong comedy was a real thing
and it was a thing of [ __ ] beauty you
know and i loved it
i loved [ __ ] uh doing what i had to
do
but then i started looking at comedy
from a different perspective i started
looking at comedy as like
well i'm gonna use it like lenny bruce
i'm gonna use it as a vehicle
to get high to talk [ __ ] party
because nothing's ever really gonna
happen i mean one of my chances of
getting an evening at the improv
what are my chances of getting hbo what
are my chances of any of those things
i don't know any of those people so i'm
never going to get those opportunities
so i was already prepared
to live the life of lenny [ __ ] bruce
and just travel get in the car with two
comics
make whatever they want to pay they want
to pay you 150 you take 150 and you make
it work
but at least you're doing what you want
i wasn't doing what people told me to do
i wasn't doing what my mother wanted me
to do
i was doing what was making me [ __ ]
happy
and that's a big difference happy is how
many of you [ __ ]
are lawyers doctors dentists i.t people
because you wanted to please your
parents think about that
and i am not mad at you because where
i'm going with this
is gonna you know i'm not mad at you but
at the same time i want you to please
yourself i want you to go jesus christ
i gotta sit here for eight hours and
then information or whatever i'm doing
the computer
is this what brings me [ __ ] happiness
do i look
forward into going into [ __ ] work
well
if that's not your answer maybe you're
doing the wrong thing but that's a
complete different [ __ ] story
you know when i did comedy i didn't do
comedy [ __ ] richard pryor
i did comedy just to keep the [ __ ]
moving just to keep lying to myself
like i've always have i've been lying to
myself for years oh yeah whatever
tomorrow will come this weekend i'll
make 300 and pay the pager bill
whatever the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you
were going for
then something happened it became real
like it became something that
um i may have a [ __ ] chance at this
and then i got a little off of [ __ ]
you know cbs to do a pilot and now i
am in l.a hmm this is [ __ ] weird i'm
a convict i'm a felon this [ __ ]
is supposed to [ __ ] happen and then
little by little i got a taco bell
commercial and then i got led into the
[ __ ] comedy store
i hope you enjoyed the [ __ ] comedy
documentary this week
it was [ __ ] good the comedy store
it's gonna get better last week as last
next week is the last week so if you
don't have showtime
get it right now then i got into the
comedy store and then i started you know
making little waves so maybe this was my
calling
and then i remember coming home like in
98 or something 99
and doing like rascals and having like
40 of my friends come out that were
my friends when i was robbing people
they weren't my friends
for comedy they were my friends way
before the comedy thing even happened we
were drug friends or
we bought drugs together we did
something some of them didn't do drugs
they
just believed in me a certain way and i
remember being rascals on stage and
seeing that audience and seeing those
people
and going now i'm [ __ ] now i have to
keep pushing with this
because if not these 18 people are gonna
ask me what the [ __ ] happened to my
comedy career
like why didn't you quit like you know
comedy was something that i was gonna
quit whenever i got arrested
you know like i knew eventually i'd get
arrested [ __ ] drugs in the hotel room
or something like that
but that wasn't happening i was
blossoming so i started working a little
harder
and you know i still wasn't getting
nowhere but i was at the store
and then something happened to me that
really you know when people look at your
the events in your life somebody said to
me on patreon the other day i'm not
looking
to get laid i'm looking for somebody to
get older with
i in my world i wasn't looking to get
old with anybody
my idol is [ __ ] charles bronson and
all the charles bronson movies
he just drifts off into the sunset after
he kills everybody
that was all i wanted to do after after
they're all dead he just
walks down the road a [ __ ] path and
he goes back to his shitty apartment on
1313 mockingbird lane i don't [ __ ]
know where the [ __ ] the guy lives
i'm just saying to you that was and that
was my motto in life but then
boom i met a girl and she was more than
a girl
you know she didn't give a [ __ ] that i
was broke she didn't give a [ __ ] about
my addictions you know she gave a [ __ ]
that i hadn't paid my taxes in seven
years
she gave a [ __ ] that how can you live
your life without a driver's license
you don't have a driver's license what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
she's like when you pay child support
you don't keep the [ __ ] receipts
like she just changed my life you know
so i had to
start adjusting to this girl and that
was everything i didn't want
once you get married and you get
divorced and you get taken divorced
you look at marriage like [ __ ] you i'll
date you for 22 years
but i'm not gonna marry nobody again i
started looking at going what am i gonna
do about this [ __ ] girl
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do about it but
guess what again
i get hit up on this i got
oh you don't meet the guys i answer
emails i
read your emails i probably got six
parents maybe ten people i'm actively
talking to
that their kids have opiate problems and
drug problems
and i don't know what to say to them i i
really don't
they hit me up and my kid what did you
do
you know and after thinking about it
again
you don't do anything for anybody
you do things because you want to do
them
but when it came to quitting coke and
quitting drugs
i didn't want to do it i i had i didn't
have drugs
quitting drugs was not my plan hey i
wouldn't be funny anymore
that's what my psyche thought and b
i just didn't find a reason
to stop doing drugs but then little by
little
like in 2002
after i was a terry for two years i
actually
went to like la city run
rehab i had to go under like a [ __ ]
alias name
you know they didn't ask for id and i
went there maybe for four days and i
didn't last i just ran the [ __ ] out of
there
and i was like that's it i'm defeated
and i watched the movie ray
you know and i saw how he got high
though he was in his [ __ ] 60s
and that didn't seem cool to me that
just didn't seem cool to me it didn't
seem like
it was an option for me to tackle i
didn't want to [ __ ] be high i was 66
that's what i want i have 18 dollars in
my bank account every day
and then and you know every day i live
for 60 dollars
20 for a bag of [ __ ] weed and forty
for a bag of coke and maybe another ten
for chinese food
that was all i was getting out of life
that was all i wanted
that it had to end people around me were
blush
blossoming with comedy yeah i was
booking movies i was booking taxi i was
booking spider-man 2
i was booking along this yard i was
booking tv shows
but i wasn't even living up to my
[ __ ] full potential
not even living can you imagine walking
into a room and booking the longest yard
and you're really running on 30
batteries are you kidding me
you know what happened if i would have
been running on 100 but i would have
[ __ ] destroyed that [ __ ] movie
thank god i was on 30 [ __ ] batteries
i was i didn't know
who or what the [ __ ] i was all i cared
about was where the next line was coming
from
and to my defense on that movie the
first six weeks i had movie i didn't
start coping we were in new mexico
i think i fell off the wagon one night
but besides that i wasn't coke addicted
like
listen doing coke and having it in your
bloodstream for three or four [ __ ]
days in a row affects your [ __ ]
mind and it affects your decisions and
what you're gonna do
from the middle of all this [ __ ] one day
i woke up at 4 45
i woke up at like 3 30 because i had to
be at torrance at 4 45
and i saw that my wife had laid out
my football uniform for me like she had
actually got up when i was in the shower
and
laid it out for me and put in a bag
and i'm like this is more than a
girlfriend
and this is more than a friend that i
have here
i have to figure something out here some
people have girlfriends
some people have friends i had the
opportunity to have it combined
she had become my best friend and she
had become
somebody who i was in love with and i
knew that
jesus christ like you could go to 12
rehabs
you could talk to wisdom counselors you
could have exorcism stuns to you when
you don't want to stop doing drugs
you're not going to stop doing drugs you
have to stop
really really really really really hard
to stop doing that [ __ ] look and if i
look at what i've done
listen when i february 19 1997
i decided after 10 [ __ ] years of
karate
i wasn't going again and i never went
back and that was the end of that
you know i've done things in my life
that have been
so [ __ ] positive yet they've become
so negative but at the end of it when
you look at it it's positive
because i broke clean from it you know
i was telling mike you know i used to do
joey karate videos
we were doing one a week then we got
greedy we were doing tool week
then it became the law diminishing
returns we started doing three a week
and the numbers went down and
i knew right away to pull the plug the
guy i was doing them with was
still a dear friend of mine was like nah
it's okay to have a few bad weeks no
it's not
it's time to pull the plug on joey
karate and i never did joey karate again
i would do things in my life that when i
said
were not going to happen again they
never happened again that's it
from the other day i had some friday
night i went out to dinner
we went to a pizza joint me mercy
my wife lisa and my boyfriend eddie
and i grew up with eddie and we were
talking about clubs that people used to
go to
and there was this club in fairview
called contestants and ritual park or
something
never wanted it my pride to this day is
that i never walked in it
i didn't give a [ __ ] who was going down
there i didn't give a [ __ ] what
drugs they had i had to make it a point
not to go down there to [ __ ] with people
because when i tell you that i'm
sticking to something i'm sticking to
something when i think i'm gonna do
something
i'm gonna do something so i came back
one day
when i woke up one morning from being
all [ __ ] up
i looked at terry and i was like you
know what man
i don't know much about life but i know
this
chick if i keep up at this point my
cocaine use was
i was doing probably
i was averaging a grammar night but
usually
throwing down two i would do the early
gram
and then the 2 a.m gram and that was
towards the end and that was if i was
home
if if i was on the road it was all men
for himself
every man for myself i was tipping the
scales at 400
and i knew it was just a matter of time
so i had to pick something
or somebody to [ __ ]
dedicate my life to because i didn't i
wasn't doing it for me
that that's the scary thing like you're
never doing it for you
pick somebody pick a mother a father a
sister a brother
somebody who's had your back constantly
and you [ __ ]
you spit in their face by using and for
me it was terry
for me i took the person closest to me
and there was also a little bit of rogan
in there
it was rogan it was a lot of terry a
little bit of rogan
a little bit of all my friends because
where this was going
i had to have my friends involved on
this
but the first thing i picked was terry i
go i don't want terry
picking me up off the [ __ ] floor the
last thing i want is that poor girl to
wake up
she goes to piss she brushes the teeth
and then she's going to make coffee to
feed the cats
she sees my fat legs laying on the
[ __ ] kitchen floor
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
[ __ ] help
that's not gonna help her you know what
there's people like me
i'm cut out to find you on the floor
i'll hold you i'll kiss you i'll dial
9-1-1
and i can move the [ __ ] on but there's
some people
who really can't find you on the floor
and she would have been one of them she
would have been
30-something years old finding a man on
the floor that was 44-45 and that would
have affected her future relationships
that would have affected her life
because she's not from that cut
so i knew this was going to end when the
cat got sick
this story is on wikipedia that a cat
ate my coke
who writes these things where do you get
your information from
bro i used to hide the coke so much i
had a hard time finding it
if i couldn't find my coke how the [ __ ]
were the cats gonna [ __ ] find it
i was doing coke one night and my wife
called me to tell me that she had to
bring two cats upstairs that they were
at the
at that's door and i came up and i went
in the bathroom and actually one of them
i really liked me outside
but the one of them i wasn't too crazy
about his name was super bad
and i looked at them both and i did my
line of coke in the house which was a
rule
that i would adhere to no coke in the
house for some reason that night
i didn't want to go back downstairs to
cats this that
something maybe do coke in the bathroom
with those two cats in there
and the next morning one of the cats
died and i feel
terrible so the cat i didn't like lived
i ended up taking him in i swore that i
wouldn't do coke
out of respect for that cat and here we
are
about to go into 13
[ __ ] years of no coke
but joey you do edibles and then
and then whatever you do xanax and
collect listen i do kalanapon big
[ __ ] difference
and i'll take you upstairs they're all
left i gotta go back to the doctor
november 4th
the doctor even told me because i can't
believe you have some left i go you know
what
after a while i had to kick him in new
jersey i had to go straight
once i started doing the podcast and
getting back into my flow of things
everything went away all the anxiety
went away the little anxiety i have
dragging in me i just work at things out
i just do a workout now
if i feel anxiety coming in on me in the
morning i skip
everything i get on a bicycle and i do
my little 30 minute [ __ ] jaunt around
the neighborhood
i see [ __ ] flying squirrels i see
raccoons i see everything i get
but that's what you do yeah i don't sit
still i hit my book
and the whole thing so part of my
quitting cocaine
was not going to an aaa meeting it was
not going to a psychiatrist
it was not going to a voodoo doctor it
was none of the above there's no magic
drink
there was no magic nothing what happened
was
i put myself out there for somebody a
and two i found the root of the cause
and i moved on from it for me it was
four different pains combined into one
my dad's loss my mother's loss
me losing my daughter in the [ __ ]
divorce
and just me being all around the [ __ ]
loser
i had these four pains once i got
through them and processed them there
was nothing i could do about my daughter
i couldn't bring my wife back my dad i'm
not houdini
and i can't do over the things
that i did i couldn't do that they're
done already
and they're gonna be done but what i
could do
is be better than what i was yesterday
and that's where my friends came in
i took lubes i took devo i took the
doctor
i took gear i took all the friends the
people who [ __ ] all those years
put up with the brunt of [ __ ] from
people and this included rogue and also
i took all those people and i
did one thing i went out of my way
to make them proud of me from my friend
george
to grandma i never wanted them to hear a
negative [ __ ] thing about me again
whatever negative thoughts they had
about me 20 years ago
30 years ago was left 30 [ __ ] years
ago
today i'm a different [ __ ] dude
and today i've gained their respect and
their love
because i turned myself around not to be
on the cover of some magazine
not i turn myself around for them
to prove to them that their love towards
me and what they did for me
was not in vain it was not going to go
unnoticed
when i got the longest shot i brought
them to the premiere
including my teachers when i got grudge
match i brought them to the
know how many people i'm gonna be
allowed to bring to the soprano premiere
but i'm gonna try my best to anybody i
let down like my friends that had that
i'd bring them
it's a movie but guess what it's not a
bad movie
it's better than you bailing me out of
[ __ ] jail it's better than you
[ __ ]
uh getting attacked by somebody where's
coco he [ __ ] robbed my house
those days are long on they were long
gone 20 [ __ ] years ago
so if you're looking for that person you
got the wrong person we change
every seven years and this [ __ ]
pandemic has changed us in eight months
it's changed the way that we've thought
and some have gone some of this has got
have gotten stronger some of this has
have gotten weaker
but you know the pandemic is here
we're gonna have to live through it and
we make the best that we can
take your vitamin d take your [ __ ]
zinc
avoid all [ __ ] stupid situations
and try your best to stay healthy get
your sleep drink your water
gargle with listerine if you eat some
bad ass gargle with listerine
if you suck a bad dick goggle with
listerine you don't wanna go in gargle
30 seconds
it's gotta hit your throat to take all
those germs out of that and that's it
but
don't ever not say you're not doing
anything for anybody because at the end
we're doing it for somebody if it's
addiction
pick somebody in your family somebody
who's giving you ten dollars when
they knew they shouldn't have given you
ten dollars when they enabled you maybe
pick them and go just for you enabling
me
i'm gonna prove to you that i'm better
than [ __ ] what you thought i was
and this all turned around for me so at
the in the beginning when i thought that
my daughter's wrong for doing this [ __ ]
for me
then i thought back about how i lived my
life
and if i'm if i'm lying to you
whatever i got clean for my friends so
they could be proud of me
not so i could be a successful comedian
or whatever
i just wanted them to be proud of me
[ __ ]
man 13 [ __ ] years
you know next monday when we're doing
this podcast
no no no two weeks from now it'll be 13
[ __ ] years that i got away from that
curse ask me do i have an urge
not at all do i want to go back to that
life not at all
i enjoy not having 18 dollars in my bank
account
i don't have much more dollars than that
my bank account now
but having 18 is everything is a [ __ ]
nightmare over a [ __ ] addiction
i beat this [ __ ] addiction yeah you
dabble in weed and you eat some edibles
from time to time oh throw me under the
jail go [ __ ] yourself
meanwhile you're drinking drinking and
driving so don't [ __ ] judge nobody
i'm just trying to keep it
as low and [ __ ] damage free
as i can but if you're having a hard
time in your life if you're having a
hard time in this pandemic
yes i want you to do it for you i want
you to try to move ahead for you
i want you to get classes to
for you i want you to do all these
things for you but
if you're like me and you have no self
value towards yourself like
you know i don't give a [ __ ] then do it
for somebody
look around who can you make proud whose
day can you make
who can you look at and then go jesus
christ man
i can't believe you [ __ ] did that and
it's not about the money or anything
like that
it's about doing something that other
people are like man i'm proud that that
guy's my [ __ ] friend
i've seen him eating dog [ __ ] for years
and now look what he's doing
people are proud of you people pick you
up through your [ __ ] backs remember
listen man
i can't pick you up you got to pick
yourself up i could put out a hand
you following the saying and we could
grasp hands but i can't pick you up all
the way
you got to pick up that last leg and
push yourself
up that's it for the week it's monday
the week of october 25th we did it we're
still here
trick-or-treat boo before the podcast is
over i want to cover one thing and i
want to come to
cover this as simple and as uh
non-aggressive but threatening listen
this podcast from here on in and even
towards the end of the church
without busting these balls or whatever
i never wanted
i'm not here to inspire hate i'm not
here to inspire problems i don't want
any problems
i want my life drama from a 57 year old
gentleman with a daughter's just trying
to raise a daughter yes i'm at fault i
smoked my reefer ooh he's a bad person
but i'm a fan
i'm a fan of a lot of things i'm a fan
i'm a big fan of charles bronson's
i'm a big fan of julius irving i'm just
a fan of things i'm a big fan of richard
pryor
there's things i'll do and there's
things i won't do
uh you know i went to 10 julius irving
games when i was a kid when he played
for the sixers
and i would go and yell julius i bet
you're heavy
and i would break his balls and whatever
but that was it that that was it that's
what you guys do when you come to the
show joey
tell us about [ __ ] uh you know
whatever his name is uh the dilorenzo
kid
moondust whatever the [ __ ] i used to
call him uh
you know i don't mind that [ __ ] that's
just the way it is but we have a problem
today
we have a big problem and i want this
addressed and i want this
just taken care of so everybody knows
the story and what happened
i love charles bronson i love him to
death
i love all his movies from [ __ ] the
magnificent seven
to the evil that men do to death wish to
death hunt
there's not anything you know uh the one
with the watermelons i love charles
bronson
if it was up to me i would love to see
for the world to see
the real charles bronson and just little
clips of his movies i could do that
but i have a problem it's called
copyright
it's called permission it's called a ton
of things i'd have to contact a bunch of
people to do it
and you know what at the end of the week
who the [ __ ] am i
just go get your own charles bronson
experience just go watch a movie and you
watch
a movie each week last night talk to my
man rick ramos
he was watching stone cold whatever the
[ __ ] it is he made a movie uh
stone something whatever anyway i i
smoked reefer this morning the point
being is
a couple months ago a couple years ago
we started a youtube page
and it's called the church page and we
were doing business with
uh somebody else and mysteriously
a page started showing up joey diaz
clips
and they're [ __ ] showing your stuff
they're taking your stuff and they're
showing it
you know why we stopped playing music on
the podcast i love
introducing new music to you guys in the
podcast something to set the tone for
the [ __ ] podcast you know what i'm
saying
it's like going to stab somebody before
rich ramirez is killing people he was
listening to ac dc right
we all want to stab somebody to a
soundtrack yes or no
i do the same thing for the day before
you get up in the morning you want to
[ __ ] put it
but on youtube they don't allow you to
play music and that's just the way it
is so we had to stop [ __ ] playing
music and you guys got mad joey no music
i want to be around listen listen to it
on your own
we can't do it on that because you get
flagged and you get so many flags
then you get thrown off youtube and then
you don't have a platform
so if you're gonna take my stuff and put
it up on youtube
and contradict what i'm doing that's a
[ __ ] problem
that's a big problem now i appreciate
you
as a family as a church family member
and a joint family member for you to
put up a video from time to time or
whatever but when it contradicts
what we're doing there's a problem this
week we had to take down some of these
[ __ ] pages that we
warned them about not putting the albums
up we weren't being bad people
we just even gave a friendly warning
listen man
you got to take those down and at first
he listened
and took him down then he decided
to put them back up to break our balls
and
my management not michael klein michael
klein doesn't know anybody it's [ __ ]
youtube
okay it's like you can just pick up the
youtube
my management no name dropping here they
have a fantastic
relationship with youtube
and there's a reason why which you don't
need to know
and i don't need to tell you i'm just
telling you
if you put something up and it's you
don't get permission from us
it's gonna get taken down
it's not that we're being bad people it
was that is that we were being good
people for too [ __ ] long
and then people took advantage that's
what it was
not that i'm a bad guy i answer your
emails
i give you content i'm as sweet as i can
to you be
to to you people as as much as i can be
there's people who don't even return
your [ __ ] emails and you guys know
who those people are
so don't come coming to me with your
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm as sweet as can
[ __ ] be
i'm sweet as cherry pie i'll give you
the shirt off my back
but when you contradict me we have a
[ __ ] problem
you want to make a [ __ ] you know it's
for you people who contact me up
hey joey if you'd like we come over and
help you with the sound do you think
that maybe
i like this sound i wanted it to be raw
this was the point of this [ __ ]
podcast
to bring it back to being a podcast not
for you guys just to see you can sit
there every day
and go we don't like his studio who the
[ __ ] are you dr like your studio
if you don't like your studio and the
sound of the podcast or the way the
camera shot
go do it yourself better but don't sit
there
and try to offer me help i don't want no
[ __ ] help from you people at all
at all i just want you to listen to the
podcast giggle
get something from it and enjoy don't
worry about uncle joey's cat on the
[ __ ] sunday how the cats do it
who gives a [ __ ] it's saturday go get
some your dick suck that's what you need
to go get
you get the weirdest things from people
like listen
the management i'm with they cover you
everything graphic designers
they come with the whole thing so we're
good there people i love you to death i
understand
and i also understand how it happens
some people show up offering you
something
but they really want something at the
end you follow them
saying to you before we even take
something we don't want to know what
that is
so we just say no because nobody comes
at you with an open heart no more amen
i really want to help you fix that flat
no i want you to help you fix your flat
butt there's a by the way
i need for you to come to the [ __ ]
thing and
i don't want no by the way i'm too old
for a [ __ ] by the way
if you got your feelings hurt by us
taking your page down
i'm very sorry we asked you very nicely
and we were gentlemen to you
my management did it my client had
nothing to do with it
number two how bored are you
how bored are you how bored are you that
you gotta go
and take clips and put pages up and
whatever
i appreciate it i love that you love me
and
lord knows i love you you found clips i
never saw before
but can you imagine you actually went
and called producers from movies
that i was on and tv shows you didn't
have that right
and you did all this without even
sending me a [ __ ] email
and asking me joey this is what i want
to do you want to do something with
joanna
just send me a [ __ ] email go to
twitter you know i'm always on twitter
there's a confusion
there's twitter there's facebook there's
patreon
there's [ __ ] gmail you never sent me
none you never sent me a form
to ask me permission for me to sign off
on
listen if you're making a couple dollars
i'm not mad at you about the dollars
it's the contradiction okay so for you
people
do not get it wrong i'm a sweetheart of
a guy
believe it or not whether you want to
believe that or not
i don't give a [ __ ] we're here we're
queer
we're just looking to have a good time
we're trying to keep it [ __ ] positive
i'm not here busting your balls about
voting or communism
or whatever all we're trying to do is
tell you a story
compare it to what's going on today and
just keep this line of communication
open because i think this is very
important the month without me doing the
podcast broke my heart
and i'm sure it broke a lot of yours we
have each other we
we [ __ ] count on each other and
that's what this podcast is all about i
count on you guys you count on me and
together forget about it
it's like two [ __ ] on halloween it's
going down [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
my heart goes out to the gay community
in hollywood next week
i don't give a [ __ ] the kids [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't need no [ __ ]
diabetes
but [ __ ] they need that diabetes my
heart goes out to them
in west hollywood the whole lgbt
community
who is not gonna get to experience
[ __ ] halloween next saturday night
but if i know anything about you bad
[ __ ]
you're gonna invade [ __ ] down here
with covert juice
and [ __ ] sling some dick down santa
monica boulevard
they can't stop your halloween they
can't stop your halloween gay parade
they can't [ __ ] reign on your [ __ ]
parade hollywood
so gay my gay brothers and sisters in
hollywood eric roach are leaving
leading the pack don't let them take
[ __ ] hollywood from you
like ozzy said don't take rock and roll
you're not
taking [ __ ] halloween from the
[ __ ] gay people in hollywood i love
you guys
i hope you have a great [ __ ] week
stay black
listen just get permission okay that's
it
just send the form and go this is what
my intentions are
you're gonna make a couple dollars a
month i don't give a [ __ ] about the
money you make
it's when you contradict what we're
doing brother
okay that's it that's that i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart
i want you to have a [ __ ] great week
don't worry about the election
don't worry about the colvin just worry
about how you're going to make it
through the [ __ ] day today
people call me up hey what are you doing
next sunday i'm gonna stab your mother i
have no idea
i'm here today today i'm here i'm
focused
we're gonna eat good we're gonna sleep
good we're gonna write our journal
we're gonna get a little healthy we're
gonna try every day
and that's all we could do [ __ ]
i love you
thank you for listening thank you for
watching uncle joey's joint
[ __ ] october 25th monday this is
gonna be the best [ __ ] week of your
life i don't give a [ __ ] what they tell
you
stay black [ __ ]
here we go i want to thank our sponsors
for always having our back
number one on it listen alpha brain
is the one that got it started alpha
brain works through nootropics
if you do not like alpha brain you start
a cycle
if you feel unfocused you can't get your
thoughts together
if you try alpha brain and you don't
like it you keep the product and you get
100
money back guarantee when a company does
that that's a company i want to do
business with
start with alpha brain they have a
smaller container
just do it for four five weeks you'll
feel the difference immediately
if not call on it tell them listen i
didn't feel [ __ ]
i didn't get any vivid nightmares
whatever i want my money back and i'll
give you your money back that's a real
product right that's a real company
shroom tech commune shroom tech sport i
live by these [ __ ] things i even did
an extra workout saturday
it wasn't an hour workout enough it was
like 30 minutes
it's because i use the shroom tech sport
the shroom tech immune
i don't have to tell you what's going on
right now i mean you could do whatever
you want on your own
but it helps honor is a great company
they've been with me since day one
and that's why i want to pass on what
they have to offer to you so go to
honor.com right now
and press in church and get 10 percent
off
your first order the the joint is also
brought to you
by draftkings if you want to have a
party
you got to have [ __ ] draftkings you
all knew
[ __ ] khabib was going to go through
gaijin they
intimidated you they scared you you
probably bet on gage it was a good
[ __ ] line gay g
plus two whatever is a great line you
know baseball was great this weekend
[ __ ] the devil raised came back on
saturday night
who knows what's gonna happen on sunday
night you may have baseball this week
but i just want you to know draftkings
is here for you draftkings is america's
top-rated sportsbook app
and if you haven't tried them yet what
the [ __ ] are you waiting for
this saturday halloween it's time for
the showdown and happy valley
what does that mean joey i'll tell you
what it means money [ __ ]
penn state versus ohio state the game is
always a [ __ ] barn burner
to celebrate draftking sportsbook is
giving all new users the chance to turn
one dollar into a hundred dollars by
just
betting on either team edit one dollar
into a hundred dollars
it's an age-old rivalry [ __ ] spirits
will be wrestling in the [ __ ]
in the green room whatever the [ __ ] you
call it you can't lose you get your
susquehanna
weed ready and they're giving all new
users a chance to receive a signing
bonus
of up to a thousand dollars when you use
code joey so that's
the sign up bonus and better dollar to
win a hundred guys
uncle joey's always got something up his
sleeve and it's called
getus you put in one grand they give you
one grand who else has given you
anything these days
you can't even get unemployment on the
phone even if you're spanish
[ __ ] you it's safe secure and reliable
depositing withdrawal money and your
convenience it's your [ __ ] money
so do me a favor right now while we're
talking right go to your phone
download download the top-rated
draftking sportsbook app now
and use code joey right now you can't
miss this offer you can't do it
you get the [ __ ] dollar for it to
better 100 and then you get a thousand
dollars to sign up
are you [ __ ] rito what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
picking the penn state ohio state put
one dollar on both of them and you win
100
right now draftking sportsbook promo
code joey remember one thing
here's what the lawyers make me say you
got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana or pennsylvania only
if you live in iowa go roller skating i
don't know what to tell you
deposit bonus requires 25 times play
through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
book for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help 1-800
gambler and if you're in indiana and you
need help call one eight hundred
nine with it but if you're ready to rock
and roll
and ready a lot of candles on somebody's
[ __ ] and blow it out
happy birthday go to draftkings
sportsbook app
and use promo code joey and let's get
this [ __ ] paper going
i love you [ __ ]
see you next week see you wednesday
[Music]
so
[Music]
you